Sheil I don't want to be a backseat
driver but you're now inside theall I
don't
like more people
Town townies welcome to another episode
of dumb people Town population you
population nonera AA Nera welcome to the
show thank you for welcome back thanks
for being here I know the this is the
non live I know the live one was really
fun it wasun spell
house what a wonderful place to be
godamn it was you and the guys we [__]
girls right no it was you and Michael
chicha oh yeah I think I was like so
nervous before and he he said something
like he was like you'll be fine and I
was like why am I getting
up you were more than fine you were
great you were great you were like psych
that he was on the show and he's like oh
man we're like dude you're so good on on
the on the news on the weekend update
and he's
like really I always feel like I'm not
there I'm not at the SP where I need to
be I was
like part of me was like I love that you
understand that and can vocalize that to
us you're not like oh yeah man I'm
kicking ass I can't handle that aspect
of you imagine any comic answer I know
I'm like that's such a comedian trait to
be like I'm horrible I'm horrible I
don't know some could there's a some
there are a few there's a certain wave
of people that I'm not going to name who
it was but I saw on Instagram post and
the guy was like update about the lady
who was yelling at my show she went out
you know and she was in the thing and
there was a fight out in the parking lot
still got a standing o at the end I'm
like why do you have to put that in I
thought this was about the lady lady who
went out I want to I feel weird I
honestly feel weird saying it was the
soldout show oh yeah tell feel weird
about that but then there's the other
part of you it's like no you want people
to know that these are coming out you
want other people to know like oh I
should come to a show then this is the
point even that I'm
like caps
we we make things AA made a book and and
she wrote a phenomenal book she make the
book she made the book wrot the book no
I made it physically I physically each
one crafted lot of binding farmed a
table we'll we'll talk about wooden and
it doesn't open just the glue the glue
cost alone no P book to and you bought
all the supplies we're going to talk
about that later but we make things we
put it out in the world and like we have
to get we have we have to let people
know that we're proud of it we just have
to I'm proud that the world is dumb I
have a story God so I'm going to get
into this story this was sent in by
Derek Shipley at dck Shipley thank you
Dereck Shipley dude sends a lot of
stories into us we appreciate you the DS
Shipley man who became trapped inside
Edmonton Public art charged with
Mischief wait in art like who are are
you I mean there's a lot there's a way
he got trapped in the art like but
that's not like I got lost got lost in
the of bir been
there like at least mentally we've
been there's the scene in Ferris speler
day off when like boom boom boom into
the beautiful this is some Modern Art
like you know there's so many like
there's a there was a modern art thing
that was like I think it was in Chicago
it was in a corner and there was just
all this candy and uh will not know what
to do with my college roommate like went
up and like took one and started eating
it like people like we're losing their
mind of course you're not supposed to do
that no there was a sign like a little
you know whatever they call it the
little description they that says take
one yes like this gets refilled every
two weeks it it was like each piece of
candy like
represented statistic all right this to
me is tells more about what's going on
with the world right now yes is that
well a long time ago but still still
this is a metaphor for what's going on
with the world right now in that like he
he took it and most people and my
reaction first was like why did he do
that but I wouldn't have gone off on him
but like you got to read the sign if the
sign says to take it right we can't just
immediately assume and there's a guy who
just did this art where he just took
glass boxes um and like he shaped them
exactly to the size of every FedEx box
and then shipped them and then however
they arrived like broken that was that
was the
art wow so I'm sure it's some sort of
Avon guard [__] interact yeah of course
like for all we know guys it's a swing
set and and that person yeah he stuck in
the she's stuck in the twist slide
that's what he's stuck in and I mean
it'd be like if someone got stuck in the
bean like I'm going to climb in the bean
how is he in it he's in it here we go
let's get into it let's get all right so
I love this story because it's weird no
one no one gets hurt I'll say that
everyone has an opinion and it happens
in Edmonton so we can crack out oh yeah
Canadian accents all right okay so a Man
became trapped inside a notable piece of
Edmonton Public art made of large silver
spheres he was arrested soon after
firefighter firefighters helped him
escape the structure Edmonton
firefighters were called to the Talis
Dome sculpture around 8:30 p.m. so you
might want to look that up Brandon and
show Alis Dome sculpture Dome did I say
the time sounds like something from dror
I know it sounds like somewhere you
would meet in like a crime movie it's a
it's a place in
Dune wasn't that a we've reached
Talis you may now release the hounds uh
all right T I gave the time sorry uh on
Sunday after someone walked wait what
time was it 8:30 p.m. after someone
walked by yeah on a Sunday so you should
be watching HBO
Sunday 8:00 p.m. you should be shutting
your [__] down you should be yeah I
always am on a low Sunday night so I'm
like this worst case scenario get
trapped in art the T oh my okay now I
understand how you get trapped you could
get trapped I can't see from here is
there space in between oh yeah I'm sure
it's like a dome but no but does it look
like it looks like a pyramid looks like
ay pyramid made of little Pebbles is in
the middle of nowhere rocks yeah it's
like just in the middle of like a field
so it does look like dude it does look
like d but it's these silver balls that
probably there is a sense of structure
that I don't think it's just the balls
because it's on a slant and like all the
balls would fall down they they have to
be attached to each all right so a man
was inside the mound of polished
stainless steel balls with no way out so
they managed to say Mound and balls in
the same sense and not talk about any
human so I was W these videos come by on
your social media and they just when
you're like I want to Now kill my brain
cells I was watching there was like a
tree branch in China and people are
walking by and hiking and literally some
guy got his head in and couldn't get it
out and I was like getting had so much
anxiety for him but I'm like what in
your brain tells you to go and into that
get in this little tree branch that's
like a triangle what in your brain says
you need to do that it's whatever told
this guy get in the structure I always
think of those people as like in the
back in the caveman days I'm like
they're the reason we move forward as a
society cuz that you have to have people
are willing to do things like that just
to see if it works and then you know one
time out of 10 it works but then the
other nine guys heads are just TR I saw
a video recently it's like a snorkeling
Excursion like Hawaii or whatever this
guy walks up to the edge so a person
jumps then he walks up to the edge then
he jumps he comes up and he's like just
flailing and he's like you don't know
how to S person goes you know how to
swim and he's like so do you know how to
swim and he goes no and he goes what
what are you do what did you and then
the guy just the guy who was standing on
the boat just yells Emily which I don't
know what that Dan I saw but think about
this like you just
said 600 years ago that guy just dies
that guy shows us how hot fire is
exactly that's what saying yeah just
like nature weeds what what was that
what was that person even what did they
think was going to happen I think they
have a brain where they don't they're
like the person who just does it without
right they don't like our bra they can't
swim yeah zero zero consequence but he
doesn't know what the consequence of not
being able to swim is Dan all he knows
is that he's like what's the worst thing
that
could Emily has to come in and save you
Emily get the net all right get the net
so here's his name the most Canadian
name ever Conor Schwin corner corner oh
Conor o r corner corner Schwin said he
was on a Post Easter dinner run what you
don't hear I've heard of the Turkey Trot
that's usually in the morning I do a 5k
after every Easter dinner I don't know
about you you're just running and puking
it's like when Michael Scott eats all
the pasta oh God Alfredo wasn't Post
Post Easter dinner din a thing yeah well
I guess so Easter brunch I don't know
yeah I thought Easter brunch D what do
you do Easter dinner or brunch well we
usually we usually have dinner on like
two or three it's an all day view so
like maybe this was like an early dinner
and he like either way who's running at
it's like Thanksgiving who's running out
oh no wait wait this might not
be oh the Connor Conor Schwin sorry is
not the guy who's trapped in Oh Sees him
he's just on he's wanted he just wanted
to brag while I was out for a run run my
Pace right now
my a five mile split our 5 minut split
48 7 minute mile whatever it's not a big
deal um he said he was on a run past
sculpture uh pass the sculpture perched
on the edge of Fox Drive and the qunel
bridge when he noticed a commotion qu no
not as good as Chipotle I know
firefighters so they can't toed Bridge
so this newspaper can't get quotes from
the firefighters or the guy they're just
getting the guy who noticed what's going
ran by and saw firefighters were saw
yeah I saw them they were attempting to
extricate the man Schwin said he asked
firefighters if it was a man or animal
trapped inside why do we need to know
this in the news article well we got a
raccoon up there is that a bear in there
or a guy Connor was the one on the run
and con's on the run and he sees a
commotion by the art piece and he's like
well they're trying to extract something
in there so when he learned that it was
a person inside he began documenting the
incident on his phone and poked his head
inside the sculpture for a closer look
oh I'm sure the firefighters he's also
the problem why is he putting his head
in there what if he got stuck what if
this is the point of the art piece to
show how our curiosity can get us into
trouble and it works it's exciting it's
also so
grammable it's so so grammable and this
is a fully immersive art project if I'm
the artist I'm like you're welcome for
the very reason that she said he said
the man in the structure was beginning
to Panic of course of quote it was kind
of like watching a mouse fall into a
bucket I've never heard that phrase ever
what does that mean Dan you can set up
these traps where it's a ramp right and
then once you get to the top of it
you'll go the animal will go to get the
food and then they just fall in the
bucket you just collect like seems so
mean well it's actually if you get to
infest it's pretty Humane because then
they just they're in the bucket and
they're all alive and release them in
someone's house that must be like some
kind of fraternity hazing a ramp into a
bucket get the Emily get the M bucket no
I mean the the Rush pledges fall the
bucket they go down get in the bucket
get in the bucket just smearing off ice
I don't never want to hear the phrase
get in the bucket you say there's a
smearing off ice in the bottom on a
string on a string and you reach for it
and fall into the bucket okay uh he said
he was kind of just running around
inside of it and started to freak out
because he couldn't get out yeah by the
way running around inside of it there's
no way go like do you think if you just
run really fast like it'll undo itself
and then police say the the weekend in
that Super Bowl bouncing off the wall he
can't feel his face his lips are
ginormous he said uh police say the man
had climbed on top of the structure and
be only let me qualify that because in
the in the Super Bowl thing he had like
all this facial work done right wasn't
that like oh I don't remember part of
the thing I don't remember he was like
yeah he had all this like crazy his face
was like all botoxed out I don't
remember not in life I think that was a
thing oh it's part of the part of like
his get up like he was making a point no
that's good making a point or maybe he
got stung by 27 be right before he got
on there stop Thomas J police say the
man he climbed on top of the structure
and became trapped inside soon after you
don't climb on top and then we're
missing a key piece of this story going
in like to me if you're like he tried to
have sex with the structure and fell
inside like then I'd be like all right
he went in the wrong also who sees a
beautiful thing of art or an interesting
thing of Art and then says I need to
climb it a child a child yeah yeah he
was in a state of play
just a book on reconnecting with his in
child 1988 McDonald's yeah so yeah right
Dan so to exate the man the firefighters
had to cut into the structure and remove
one of the balls I'm sure the artists
love that thanks said Sarah Jackson a
spokesperson for Edmonton Fire Rescue
Services three crews including a
tech Rescue Team were one crew is needed
the other two were there to just laugh
at take pictures let's get Back Up call
call all engine 46 they're put this on
Facebook uh no injuries reported soon
after the man slipped out of the
sculpture he was ARR back in and got
like he's
like like I forgot my phone and then
they're like oh no he he's like
attracted to it like a fetish for him
he's got to get inside the ball I can't
get hard unless I'm in the structure
police say the man caused damage to
several of the balls while climbing on
top of the structure gosh uh we're going
to get you want to guess how old he is
now sure we can guess how old he is the
how old man was charged with one kind of
Mischief Mischief uh over and then we'll
give the amount of money it was it cost
to what damage he did so how old was the
guy wait do we prosecute for Mischief
here or is
that because it's like one of those
things that does sound very Canadian
though it does sound very Canadian I
turned over all the cups at a Tim
Horton criminal mischief criminal
mischief you know your Uncle Jeff he had
criminal mischief he threw pine cones in
Susan so and soul all right so how old
do you think this um I'm going to put
him at 38 38 which is like you should
know better trying to figure out what
the rest of his life is going to be a
little midlife verging on midlife can
still do something about it if I don't
climb on the structure now when will I
climb on exactly I think he was 19 I'll
go 24 24 but I could be totally wrong I
just feels like a dumb one of you is 2
years off you guys want to go two years
in any direction so we were in were in
New York recently and we to do our show
and we went after the show to this
karaoke bar that was downstairs in like
kind of near time in near like the
Theater District near 54th in near our
old Department like Theater District but
it was like way downstairs it was very
cool bar and there was like all these
22-year-old 23y old young and they were
getting so drunk and I watched one guy
young dude who was wasted he ordered a
pizza and had a full box of pizza like
on a bench that was you know a banket
kind of Booth thing and he got up and
like knocked the pizza over and it all
fell on the floor I it felt so bad for
him it all fell on the floor and he
walked away and he stumbled back and
managed to like step on all the pie
every single piece so that's what I'm
thinking of as the guy who got into this
guy you say 19 what do you want to say
when do you change it to oh I'll change
21 do you want to go up or down two
years oh wonder about uh Should I stick
with mine or should I go up go up up or
down
3 six okay uh
22 all right get your answers in this
guy they don't say his name 26 years old
oh D could have gone the other way but
that's so he was charged with one count
of Mischief Mischief over there's a
number where there's like a they don't
tell damage of over if it's over this
you get charged with Mischief I think
it's is this Canadian money 5,000
5,000 I'm going to say
7500 7500 yeah I'm going to say 20,000
okay one of you is exactly right right
here I think that's Dan himself I'm
going to oh I'm going to switch to a
parna 7500 oh I'm going to switch to
yours you're going to switch to Mine by
the way we've never done that people
switch their things you guys like Soul
switch I know like a great 8s movie uh
the answer is 5,000
D see ours was incidental yeah we were
not we were running around inside of a
structure then this line in this article
is the to me the greatest thing ever and
now I'm into like all the debates in
Edmonton all right ready um it says the
public art installation has proven
polarizing among edmontonians for years
that's what people are mad at yeah I
don't like it my wife she likes
it I don't you're going to put it up
someone's going to get in there the fire
department's going to get called there's
going to be a fire and where are they my
cousin loves it and I can't even talk to
him anymore that guy's real I love that
this pyramid of silver balls is breaking
up families in Edmonton I won't talk to
my son
anymore he's a strange cuz he likes the
balls oh but maybe yeah Post Easter
dinner maybe someone brought up politics
in terms of the balls the balls are out
the balls are out no and that's what he
said you know what I I can't handle this
I don't want to talk about Pier Trudeau
or other Trudeau I'm going to go for a
run and you know what I'm going to do
I'm going to run by the balls cuz I like
it you would like ex are you ready for
this what is Easter dinner have to get
ruined by this discussion of the art T
Dome ruins another Easter
dinner Talis Dome one Easter dinner zero
all right hand this guy's name Hans
Claver does that not sound like a
DieHard villain Hans Claver is a fan of
the piece and he made his way down to
the rescue scene Sunday after hearing
about it on Facebook so here's what you
know about Hans he gets most of his news
from Facebook what's going on what's
going on around town what are you doing
over there H I'm reading Facebook we got
to get down to the balls we got to get
tell us he finished 12th in the world
Strongman
Competition this is him I like the balls
one of the few people who do so I came
down to have a look there was a guy
inside there he told CBS news on Monday
that I'm sure CBS News didn't ask and
he's like he went CBS news I got
something to he went to the building he
went to the
station is anybody going to record my
statement apparently he climbed up top
someplace found a hole big enough to
Slither in and Slither down inside and
then he couldn't get out Claver said
he's admired the shiny Chrome exhibit
for years and always wondered what it
would look like from the inside but has
never been curious or stupid enough to
give this is Kevin McDonald in the in
those SK the Kids in the Hall sketches
like don't put salt in your eye don't
put salt in your eye put salt in your
eye he said he met the man's girlfriend
who advised Claver that she never
thought scaling the sculpture was a good
idea which means that guy had been
talking about it I'm going to do it hone
I don't think she's going to go on the
record and say she never supported I
told him not to do she's like I'm right
about a lot of things like suddenly this
becomes and I'm right about your mom
like she calls way too much like he's
into all right uh maybe they should have
left him there overnight you know throw
him a sandwich or something Claver said
with a
laugh now he's having fun with have to
start St just throw a sandwich on the
top of the thing see if he can get so
that's the thing it's like one of the
you know I've seen videos of like people
running down like a like a
huge like decline that goes into water
and it's sand but like it's easy to go
down but it's like so hard to get up out
of the water and get out so like he's
like oh if I go in I'll come back out
and I think he jumped in too far and
he's like I can't reach I can't get up
this is classic Hans Claver though I
love him um he's the one who talked
about it right right no he's the other
guy who talked about the Talis Dome
maintained by the Edmonton Arts Council
as part of the city's Ed of Edmonton's
public art collection construct
construct in what year what year do they
make the Talis
Dome people have hated it for years
you've seen it I'm going to go 1996 yeah
this definitely feels like a I I'm going
to say9 91 right ' 80s or '90s I think
91 I'm going to go
94 okay 91 94 and what' you say 96 996
uh it was constructed in 2011 wa
instantly controversial from the
second it's not not old 12 years of
controversy it's not old at all a dozen
years it was designed by California
based artist Benjamin ball his name is a
ball in the
name and gastone no and it costs how
much how much did it cost to make I'm
going to assume cost the city of
Edmonton what do they get commissioned
to build this on this collection of
balls
BM I have a lot of questions
$100,000 I think it's like something
crazy and like that's what's upsetting
people controversy okay we're going to
spend that on this and we can't fix the
you
know what do you think part
50,000 I'm going to go low 100K
50k I'll split it I'll go 75,000 all
right get your answers in shout at your
ham radios
$600,000 oh my artwork now I understand
the controversy so now you we what for
this we paid what for what is what we
can't get another drinking fountain down
at the rec center and we got this godam
but you know there's a lot of people
being like why are we spending money on
this we need another forward on the line
on
the Schwin said his video of the
incident has gone has since gone viral
and no surprise the instulation often
referred to as the Talis balls has
proven divisive among edin ton for years
seen the guy trapped him there was
strange but seeing the social media
Fallout is even stranger he said I mean
it's so Edmonton he said how polarizing
that's so Edmonton that's is that the
Canadian that's so R it is that's so
Edmonton it's so Edmonton uh he said how
polarizing the Talis balls are is
already funny and to have some dude slip
inside there I just thought it was
humorous it's great I love that people
have that humorous I just thought it was
humorous it's so funny is it funny n
humorous more humorous than funny like a
like a chuckle on the inside that's the
first
there you go all right when we come back
that's first story down the book so par
is with us we're going to find out about
her book and we're going to let you know
where you can catch us is D people Town
don't go
anywhere
around
people hey guys welcome back to the show
uh what a wonderful we're back all of us
from our things that we did Dan recorded
his uh special we did our show in New
York our thanks to everybody who came
out for all that stuff we before we get
into what a part book and how you can
get it and you definitely should it's
good read good holiday reading good
holiday read do you read the audio book
I do yes you can get the audiobook it's
probably available on Audible you want
to walk by a tower of balls and climb in
trapped in there this is what you listen
to yeah if you have time in you got six
hours but won't it help you not feel as
bad about yourself for doing that if you
listen to that book book about
self-doubt so yes Jus you had the
courage to go in the Talis balls and now
you don't know how to get out and you're
doubting yourself read this book read
this book listen to the book so we
should let people know what we have
going on uh right Dan we'll tell you
that uh at the end of uh at the end of
this month beginning of uh December and
second we'll be in Cleveland at
hilarities which is so much fun the
beginning of January we're one night at
uh helium on the 4th and then on the
5ifth we're in at the crocodile in in
Seattle which Port helium Portland and
the crocod island Seattle and then at
the uh beginning of February we're at uh
Comedy Works in Denver the South Club uh
end of February beginning of March we're
at Mark Ridley's Comedy Castle with our
buddy Nate fritson and then uh we're in
Minneapolis beginning of April and then
moon tower and then we'll let you know
but all good stuff thank you to everyone
who's joined our patreon and we we just
appreciate all you guys for supporting
us thank God the strike is over now we
can go back to complaining why we don't
get work for other reasons but uh it is
we are very very grateful to all of you
so thank you uh apara let's talk about
the book and where people can get it I'm
so proud of you that you wrote you like
through my favorite Comics wrote books
recently oh oh I know it's been really
year of the comedy year of the comedy
book year of the comedy book and they're
all amazing and they all kind of deal
with like mental how you how your mental
health where you're at with that stuff
and I think I feel like so much of your
comedy sort of addresses it and attacks
it in like a hilarious way but in like
maybe one of the most preent ways of any
comedian doing today you and Gary
Goldman oh thanks but yeah the book is
sort of a combination of funny and
serious and was a little bit scary cuz I
think you know as a comedian you're like
I feel like people expect a certain
thing from you and then if you I guess
as any artists and then if you divert
from that thing you're like I don't know
I don't know if they will still accept
me oh I think they will because I think
again what you do so well and what we
try and figure out is the premise is the
serious part of every bit it's the truth
that's the truth it's the Nugget of what
we're the the thing that we all
experience but it allows you to go off
and be right silly
the way you look at it is funny so if we
look at whatever you bring up as the
serious parts and there are like the
premise of all this other stuff your
funny anecdotes will be the the bits so
to speak yeah well someone I think
someone wrote me on Instagram they were
like I loved your book I recommended it
to my friend they did not like it they
said they said it feels like it's
written by smart people for smart people
so then I was like oh should I really be
promoting it on a podcast called Dum
people tell abolutely absolutely this is
a show where smart people Al try to
fight the the title we're trying to
fight I'm not saying we're smart I would
take that as a compliment that smart no
I was yeah I I I did I
did well by the way we were talking
about like would you go do readings of
this book CU you just toured and I just
did stand up and I did uh signings
afterwards cuz yeah something about a
reading just frightens me I think it's
seeing everyone's face and then you're
reading it and you're kind of like is
this good and then you're looking at
them and you're you know people don't
react to readings the same way they do
to standup so you've like tested your
standup out on a bunch of smaller
readings the reading would be like if
you wrote your standup di down and had
never spoken them out loud and then read
them to a CL yeah that'd be weird but I
do think like this is what I'm going to
pitch to you for your if you do like if
a bookstore is like we really want you
to come and you're like go I think you
should read all like the the reactions
to it to your book like all the reviews
all the reviews everything oh my God or
I'm going to pitch this to you okay go
to a big time bookstore strand or Pals
yeah and you say a PARTA is going to be
here you let you let everyone know in
Portland you're going to be at Powell
Books starting at 9:00 a.m. and you're
going to do a book reading and you're
not going to leave until you finish your
whole [__] book that would be so
funny like performance art read the
whole book who is that what are those
people she's on chapter five so great
she hours to read the whole B the people
who stay the whole time you then have to
take them out to dinner that would be an
unbelievable I know I feel like those
people are not sa to be around I'm
pitching it I know you'll never book is
called the book is called the book is
called unreliable narrator yeah great
which I love that's brilliant and it's
wonderful ition in the world of
literature oh yeah Holden Coffield I
would put him up and are you the
unreliable narrator or all I am life is
we all are a little bit the reader is
somehow I feel like social media has
made us unreliable narrators everything
any narrators so where do you want
people to get the book like what's the
best place where people can get it they
go to their local bookstore and just
yeah I'm a big fan of independent
bookstores I don't know I I'm a big fan
of libraries I don't know if that's good
as you know in capitalism to be like go
get it for free go rent it yours should
be sold to every library ever right like
every Library across the country should
have your book in it yeah yeah yeah Li
love independent bookstores love
libraries love I mean I'm going to go
ahead and say you know I buy a lot of
books and I read them and then they just
sit on my shelf give your copy to a
friend once youve read it go yeah that's
the worst marketing ever why uh so no
I'm going to say don't do that I'm going
to say go go buy it
because support maybe she'll write
another book maybe someone will give her
a whole chunk of change to write another
book that's true but you when you're
done reading it I will allow you to put
it in one of those like free little free
Li little free neighborhood libraries we
open the door I always love those little
hous those are awesome all right do that
all right that's it unreliable narrator
go pick it up let's jump into Story
number two and then uh segment two
segment three we'll hear what you have
going on are you ready yes put in by
Matthew fredman not your average Matt
Matt all right here we go fun little
dumb dumb Story number two okay SUV
driven through Southshore Plaza Mall oh
just to drive through the whole Mall
drive through the mall have you ever
been to a drive he's over by Orange
Julius let him go I'll get him drop me
off right here at Spencer I need a
calendar drop me here off right here at
Spencer I need to pick up a parna book
is it available Spencer be should be
right right next to the boob hats come
on the colorful suspend ma machines the
sexually suggestive greeting cards
yes brain tree
Massachusetts a woman who a family
member said was attempting to go to the
Apple Store drove her SUV through the
walkways of a brain tree Massachusetts
mall so nice job Genius Bar way to get
assume she did not have a Genius Bar
either she didn't look up online the
driver entered through automatic
doors okay he's like well the door open
gate sure no car ever goes through
sliding glass doors no car ever maybe at
a dealership but even then I can't have
the time I can't figure out how they got
so if you're in a mall I don't know when
the last time you were in a mall I just
in a mall I go to malls a lot because of
teen I guess I was just in a a sort of
La outdoor mall okay outdoor mall is
different indoor mall like I know Indo I
go to the Westfield Mall in in Sherman
Oaks it is like malls from where we grew
up Dan and it look it looks like a mall
there's it's not big there are only two
there's a Bloomingdales and a Macy's and
then there's I like to see what are the
stores that like are surviving right now
how many candle shops there are not a
lot of candle shops there's a lid's hat
store soap stores is there still a
Wilson's Leather no there's a shoe
doctor there but then there's like
there's like a
high-end like shoes and like Street Wear
store in there which is crazy there's a
Vans there's a H&M Pack
Sun natural wonders still a store I
don't know I remember that store there a
puzz I thought there was a TV show about
a girl who was a robot no that's small
sorry no there's like a puzzles in like
game store there was a time in my life
where I was very into going into the
like sports memorabilia like framed
iconic photo
stores Michael Jordan won once okay so
those are good like M said but I'm
saying if you were in a mall and a car
just started driving through you'd be
like this is a promotion for the car
right like you'd be like oh yeah for
sure if I buy three things down there
I'm now entered into a contest to win
this car that they're showing you that
this frazzled woman crazy like have you
guys ever seen someone performing in a
mall no oh really like you us the day oh
I yeah it's usually music it'll be like
a child playing a violin or something oh
yeah seen that well yeah okay so I've
seen like
a yeah like oh yes airports too yeah
like a quartet playing something but I
haven't seen like a pop star arriving in
a mall yeah I guess I just wonder who
books the mall yeah like that's a great
question I'm just wondering where how I
how I can get in on some of this mall
action read my book in oh my God
possible place you I have another pitch
for where you can read your steak and
potato company no this is where you're
going to read your book without a
microphone Center Court in between
quarter 3 and quarter Flo four of like
the Clippers game there you go front of
like 20,000 people and you quietly just
read I just want to see you lick these
two fingers and pull one
p sitting on a chair Center Court that
would be amazing so the driver aners to
the automatic doors that was your first
shouldn't be here starts driving down
the central Corridor on the second floor
my God which also means they're like
looking down yeah right police said the
white Lincoln MKX entered the mall
through of course it's an MKX wow
through an old person car through a
pedestrian
bridge from the south garage oh my God
the garage is like so they are they
trying to play this off like a mistake
Dan or is this due to a recent accident
one of the safety uh ballards
that was missing from the front entrance
so doesn't that mean someone had tried
this before Oh God Dan I hope somebody
if it's already gone someone had ran
into that either that or they like
clipped it or something like that
surveillance video shows the SUV driving
slowly into the mall hitting a shopping
cart dock reversing and then going
around the dock that is the second
time that the mall has the mall is
telling you go in
here like when have you ever driven like
can you imagine being in the car too
with that person I think we're I think
we're just Sheil Sheil I don't want to
be a backseat driver but you're now
inside the mall I don't like hearing
people tell or like back when we were
like when you were a feature and you
were with a headliner on the road that
you didn't really know that well and you
were trying to like very be cool and be
like I I think we're probably supposed
to go back actually I should we TR
like I've never been here before either
I'm just saying like maybe
we you're trying not to uh usurp yeah
cuz you just want the time you just want
you want to bring you on more shows or
her wait so the other thing is uh
there's probably someone in her back
seat going like can you turn down the
heat about other things I'm really hot
it's getting hot back here and I don't
want to open you hit the shopping cart
talk and you're like oh you know what
let me just back up like no I think we
should probably go all the way no no no
no let I'll get around this I I'm just
looking for a safe place to turn around
and there's people walking with like
American Eagle bags like around your car
I know like when are you ever like I
don't care if it's the mall or it's like
out in the country if you are the only
car you can see think about where you
are you screwed up screwed up in Italy
there are like in the old part of like
trist like the area there there's like
little side streets that look like
they're just walking streets and all
these people and then a car will just
it's going through a and it's driving
down this thing and I feel worse for
people the car cuz I'm like how are you
not thinking you're going to hit
somebody as you're going through here
this must be the most nerve-wracking
thing ever to drive down what looks like
just a complete walking I've had so many
times like I don't think this is a road
like even like places in Wisconsin and
stuff like that but like you're in a
mall you're in a mall I barely handle
driving down a road where cars are
parked on both sides yeah sure I'm like
I don't think there's room for me some
of those cities like on the East Coast
where they just decide they could just
park in the middle yeah what are you
guys doing out here a narrow bridge
that's one way it's like that's just one
and like oh God it's a blessing no one
got hurt said Janet Parsons who
witnessed the incident oh God her kids
are on the honor roll hey uh we should
get a quote from someone who who should
we get is Parsons here Janet she's at
Auntie Annie's pretzels give her a
minute she'll come over hband has a
project the SUV took a left turn and
traveled about how many feet down the
mall's Central Corridor oh my God how
many feet do you think this car drove
before it got stopped 700 100 feet 100 I
say 1,200 feet 12 ft it drove 180 ft wow
Jes still far 60 yard 60 yards like y
over half of a football field they kept
driving the driver stopped the vehicle
outside torid four store front south of
where she entered you guys know what
torid is no what is torid well I'll tell
you torid is plus-size fashion and Trend
trendy plus-size clothing shop the
latest in plus-size fashion including
dresses swimwear jeans tops rompers
Intimates and more find trendy and Chic
outfits jackets shoes and more shout out
Tor I love it tor that's all in the
article no I just needed to know what
Tor was like I so seamless right Dan
just read that straight through I just
needed to know what Tor it was also the
reviews for the T and Brin true Ma I
went ahead and looked kind of mixed t
one woman was very pissed but also could
not
spell you know it's like your anger is
your argument is being lessened by the
fact that you can't write well no I want
if you're writing this way I want you to
not like torid yes of course cuz now I'm
going to look at that and be like I
probably would love torid Janet Parson
talked to the person in the car God this
is Janet Parsons she says do you know
how to get out of here and I said stay
right here I'll get somebody and she
kept creep creeping forward of course of
course that's been her whole life
creeping forward slowly like how many
times have you heard this ma'am ma'am
ma'am ma' ma'am no you're still moving
ma'am going forward still moving she's
like gently pushing the guard with her
car police describe the driver as
confused in a preliminary statement no
[__] right yeah was she driving Forever
21 miles hour the sister of the driver
who asked
WCVB not to use her name said she had no
idea how she did it she won't be driving
anymore end quote police said they uh
they would ask the registry of motor
vehicles to suspend the woman's license
no charges have been filed videos of w
from Witnesses showed police backing the
car down the corridor to get it out of
the building can you imagine how
difficult that would be even just to try
and back a car out of a mall no injuries
were reported thank God she doesn't get
to make a choice for the rest of her
life what do you guys want pizza or you
don't get to choose I'm sorry your
decision making is suspect did she get
her thing fixed at the Apple Store
that how old is the woman in the Lincoln
MKX it's easy to be like 88 I know I
know but I don't think it's that where
do you want to go she's younger than
that part you want to go first yeah I
guess I'll go young I'm going to say
57 57
glad 73 73 64 64 will in story to here
because the woman who drove through a
mall at some I understand being like am
I supposed to go through here like I'll
buy that right but after that it's like
no the creeping forward tells you
everything if you go past someone trying
to give you a free sample of General sty
chicken you got it you're in the wrong
place I mean you're in the right place
for life I think but you're in the wrong
place for a car yes yes okay she
is 78 years old
God bless why we won't allow our mom to
rent a car here Story three R oh my God
give us a tease on what is that we have
another erratic driving story but this
time it involves an animal as well one
last story a PARTA is with us her new
book unreliable narrator you can pick it
up anywhere at a library at an
independent bookstore
preferably borrow it buy it get it on
get it buy it as hey you know what I'm
going to say buy it as gift for your
friends for the holidays that's a
wonderful thing to give to someone a
book to read over the holidays is like
the thing I'm going to get it as a gift
for uh I know who I'm going to get it
for I love all right uh we'll be right
back with more dumb people town a and
Nell with us right after this sck
around hey gang welcome back to the show
before we jump into this final story
Daniel I'm so proud of you you shot your
special when we're recording this uh I'm
very excited and uh do you have are you
taking a little bit time off you're
doing some otheres I'm headlining Cap
City on December 14th um and then I'll
be announcing dates I'll be running the
rose gold tour up until the special
drops probably in the spring great so uh
people can still come out and and check
it out everything will be at Daniel
van.com but the the I guess the biggest
thing in addition to being a Cap City is
um my movie is coming out now that the
over you can promot it about yeah it's
called wine club I'm the lead it's a
comedy um there's great people in it uh
as well as hopefully my yourself you'll
decide when you see it um so I think
that is going to be premiering I I want
to say it's like mid December I think
it's like the 12 premiering where in
theaters online where people how can no
I think um you know the strike just
moved everything around in terms of
ttimes we could buy it so we just wanted
to put it out I think there's going to
be a Premiere in La I don't know when
that is either this is like the great
thing over your figuring out like okay
guys what happened with the movie um but
uh I I'm the lead in it you'll be able
to to watch it and check it out I hope
people do I'm proud of my performance
Steve little is in it he's amazing
Taylor Ortega uh plays my wife she's so
great um great dan.com one Club movie I
love it I absolutely love it all right
you guys ready to get in this last story
okay here we go this is sent in by Lissa
at the and it says GRL meaning girl the
girl on the wall at the girl on the wall
we need we want her on that wall we need
her on that wall thank you
and a new person sending a story so we
always love it all you got to do we're
still on I we haven't figured out
another way to do it we're still on X is
probably the best way
sadly Brothers Dan vankirk #d toown then
that way we know where the story came
and who the order of it it's just is
dated that way so we can do it that way
are you ready for the headline man
arguing with parrot pulled over for
erratic driving in Clear
Water the parrot he's he's arguing with
the parrot and he was driving I told you
he sucks at driving that's right exact
exactly don't drive into the mall right
St a year ago I'd be like Jimmy Buffett
a now there's not a ton to this story in
terms of facts but as a group we're
going to try and determine what the hell
happened here wait wait wait so how did
they know that he was arguing with the
parot when he crashed the par probably
told him exactly the the black box in
the right per can't keep it mouth shut
either dashboard can after the okay in
Clear Water Florida after the Florida
Highway Patrol Troopers received several
calls Saturday night about a man driving
erratically possibly driving while
intoxicated on US1 19 and Clear Water
Troopers Z Logan and N darling Logan and
darling does that sound like yeah that's
1980s cop show called clear called The
Waters not so clear something like that
Florida she's Logan he's darling
Lo right right yeah she's Logan and he's
darling and so whenever they show up
Logan darling and someone goes over to
the woman it's like hi darling it's like
no that's darling that's the joke of
everything y so they were located pull
over the car in clear near Clear waterer
Beach but instead of finding a drunk
driver they discovered a man having an
argument with his
parrot so he's in an argument with the
parrot like definitely this guy is like
what are they talking about what hide
the weed hide the weed am am I dumb the
the bird Birds how much cognitive
thought do theys are pretty smart I
think I believe so like could they argue
with you like the merits of likeing that
information from someone
else are you parting that unreliable
narrator unreliable narrator yeah we're
going to trust her are you kidding me
birds are so smart I think they are too
I just wonder if you could get it
they're like well you you you forgot to
pack those shoes and you're like no I
pack them I don't know about that but I
just know their ability to learn and
like oh so to be able to form language
they very very smart but I just could
you I know that crows memorize people's
faces oh yeah every animal I've ever had
I eventually talk to immediately like
it's a person in my life that I have
full on yes I think that's pretty normal
but I'm wondering like at what extent
could I be in an argument with thatal
this is I mean I've had very long
arguments with cats yes right about the
way they treat that's how they're
behaving you're talking about their
behavior like the parrot is not going to
be like your father like Game of Thrones
ended father witheld love from you
because you don't deserve it you've read
a cat the riot act that's what you've
done just a lot of like why would you do
that to me yeah don't walk away don't
walk away and it's a lot of like Get
over here get over Dan get over here to
a cat is the most
F no he likes it the old Paul F Tomkins
bit which was hilarious like the guy
who's got an exotic pet on his shoulder
at the post office like par doesn't want
to go to Costco with you that was the
argument yeah oh yeah why am I going
like you leave me I'd rather be in a
cage than have to go through and watch
you eat a crazy when we get to the part
of the story where the parrot cannot
speak yeah the guy was like he just was
stonewalling me the whole time I mean he
normally talks he give me the silent
treatment I mean what kind of friend is
that uh that's a stuffed animal sir
according to Troopers a parrot according
to the Troopers the parrot became angry
because it wanted to go home there's no
way that W that's the argument okay but
the man wanted to go to Clear Water
Beach God the parot was like take me
home right now and the man's like nope I
want to go to Clear Water breach bird is
also every woman in his life like I just
want to go home I so and you know he's
like roll down the window the parents
like roll down the window I'm hot and
he's like I'm not rolling it down roll
it down you better that's the argument
there and he's driving like a maniac and
I just want go home I just want to go
home par wants to go home yeah cuz you
know like this is what it is in my mind
the GU like I just want to go to Clare
waterer Beach and the parrot knows
because like a said par birds are smart
parrot's like we not going to just go to
Clear Water Beach you're going to want
to then go to
beer go wrestling then you R away yeah
that's great so I want to go home
because this is not the beginning you
say Clear Water Beach we're going to go
to a bar then you're not going to be
able to drive me home I know how the
night's going to go the argument
distracting the man causing him to drive
erratically if you're taking your parrot
to the beach get ready for it to fly
away is all I'm going to say like so
that's my number one I I hate people oh
I got this bird and I made it so I can't
fly well I want to go to the beach with
my parent on my shoulder so I can meet
people oh what's that what what's that
wait he said that yeah Troopers say they
de-escalated the situation and resolved
the standoff successfully deescalate it
standoff between the two big guy and the
parrot it's a domestic dispute yeah all
right Bird you got anybody can come pick
you up cuz we're not we can't let you
guys get back in the car I'm going to
separate you too guy can we take the
bird back behind the the car 500 yard
away from this bird and that includes up
okay into the air he can be right above
you but 500 yards but why wasn't the
owner de escalating it himself the owner
should you're the owner of a parrot okay
no the owner is definitely saying to the
cop tell him that he's annoying too no
tell him I hope the parrot
say
you think I wanted this man I asked to
be no and the GU like say it to my fa
face and the parot like tell him I want
to
go so this would be a hilarious Reno 911
scene Reno 91 where like dangle is like
in between be like he says he doesn't
want to be here he doesn't want to be
here Troopers uh didn't say who won the
argument I'll tell you who won the
argument the parrot the go to the beache
I would agree go the be going going God
so I'm going to show you at the end to
close things out the officer with the
parrot
smiling gorgeous bird beautiful bird You
could argue with this yeah he doesn't
deserve that bird you don't deserve this
parrot and the parrot doesn't want to go
to the beach that's a fun third story
fun third story that's it the unreliable
narrator is uh or unreliable narrator is
aa's book everybody go out and get it
get it for the holidays get it as a gift
and uh I would just want her to write
more and create more stuff and put it
out in the universe you thanks for
coming foring here I love it and no [__]
we got to get back to work
guys sck around make sound there's
[Music]
to